ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนถมสวัสดีครับเค
ก๊อปมานะครับเจอกับครัวตี้พี่เอ๋
ช่องคอมเพลนไทยโอเค
ครับผม
ก่อนที่จะสอนต้องรู้จักวันก่อนหน้ารู้จัก
วันก่อนครับวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันนี้
วันอังคาร
วันอังคารปีหาปากกาก่อนโอเคว่ะอังคารอยู่
ตรงนี้นี่วันอังคารใช่ครับอ่าวันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวันอังคารวันที่
28 ครับ
28 นายครับเดือนอะไร 4-5 เดือนนี้เดือน
ธันวาคมครับ
ทันห่มเดือนธันวาคมปีพตตคศน้ออ้ายคศ
2000  0  21 ครับ 2 คัน 20  21 ครับผม
แล้วปีพต
เท่าไหร่ผช
2564 ครับอ่า
2564 ทายครับเมื่อแล้วตอนนี้หน้าตอนนี้
เวลาใช่ไหมครับอ่าตอนนี้และลีลาเท่าไหร่
นะคะเวลาเวลาอ้าป้ายโมง
13:00 น
อีกสามสิบนาทีอ่ะหรือ 13:30 นน
พูด 13:00 น 30 นาทีโอเคพูด
13:30 นได้นะกันได้ครับ
ตอนนี้เวลา 13:30 นขับร้อน
ร้อนนิดหน่อยอ่าร้อนครับ
ครู Arty คะวันนี้วันนี้แข็งแรงดีไหมอ้า
วันนี้แข็งแรงดีครับแข็งแรงดีๆครับ
ครูเห็นผู้ปาร์ตี้ขอโทษนะคะเห็นอัพแผน
มี 9 ใช่ไหม 5 มีกล้ามนิดหน่อยปล่อย
มีกล้ามกูอาทิตย์ไปเล่นกีฬามวยไทยเหรอ
เล่นกีฬามวยไทยติมาให้เล่นกีฬามวยไทย
เอาใจเขา
อาทิเล่นกีฬาอะไรคะหาขั้วตี้ไปวิ่งครับไป
ของวิ่งซ้ายหน้าวิ่งตอนเช้าตอนเช้าไปวิ่ง
อาบหน้าเช้ากี่โมงคะตอนเช้า
05:00 นไป 5 ประมาณอ่าตรงนี้ครับ
5:00 น
5:00 นราคา
ดี 5  Km นัด 5:00 นให้ครับวิ่ง
วิ่งนาน R  R กี่ชั่วโมงป่าวิ่ง 1
ชั่วโมงชั่วโมงให้ครับ 1 ชั่วโมง
ครู Arty ชอบกีฬาวิ่ง 5 ใช้ครับชอบกีฬา
วิ่ง
ครูเอ๋นอนๆแต่
5:00 น 05:30 นนอน
โอเค
ไม่ได้วิ่งแต่ครูเอ๋เออ่กีฬามั้ย
เว้นเล่นกีฬาอะไรครับอ่ะโยคะอ๋อ
โยคะใช่ไหมครับเดี๋ยวขาก็หญิงอื้ออื้อ
โยคะอ่าใช่ครับโยคะ
ดันแค่นี้มิโยคะทรายครับนะ 5 แบบนี้ตึง
ดื่มอ่าไงครับ
โยคะใช่ไหมยกนิดหน่อยหน่อยๆดีครับวันนี้
นะคะพูดว่าครู Arty ชอบไปวิ่งๆชอบกีฬา
วิ่งไทยครับเพราะวันนี้มีกีฬาให้นักเรียน
ดูใช่ไหมครับๆๆวันนี้ครัวตี้มีกีฬามีหลาย
ๆอย่างให้นักเรียนดูหน้านะครับ
นายได้ครับมีลาอะไรคะอ้ามีกีฬาอันที่ 1
นะครับอ่าไปดูกีฬานี้นี่ครับๆไม่รู้ตอน
ก่อนอ้า Google ให้ครับอ่ะอุปกรณ์กีฬากร
กีฬาอ๋อกลมกลมๆสีขาวกลมสีขาวใช่ครับ
เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้เป็นรูปลูกกอล์ฟครับ
ลูกกอล์ฟ
ช่างหลังลูกกอล์ฟมีอายข้างหลังนี้เป็นไม้
ไม้กอล์ฟนะเวลาเล่นเราใช้ไม้กอล์ฟตีตีตี
ลูกกอล์ฟใช่ครับลูกกอล์ฟและลูกกอล์ฟอยู่
บนสีฟ้าห้าสีฟ้า
ที่วางๆเป็นที่วางนะครับอ่ะถ้าเราเรียก
พิมพ์ไหมเป็นพิมพ์ที่ตั้งลูกกอล์ฟไว้ข้าง
บนอ่าใช้ครับ
อีกกอล์ฟออกแล้วก็มีสนามนะทรายมีสนามหญ้า
กว้างๆใช่ครับ 5  4 กอล์ฟ
ก็พูดว่าสนามกอล์ฟได้ครับสนามกอล์ฟเนาะกู
Arty มีอุปกรณ์กีฬาคือลูกกอล์ฟไม้ตี
กอล์ฟขับตายนัดนักกีฬานักกีฬาก็ก็พูดว่า
อะไรคะนักกีฬาเราพูดว่านัดกอล์ฟ
อ่าใช่ครับนี่นักกอล์ฟมีเขากำลังตีกอล์ฟ
Natty ปรายนี้ใช้ไม้กอล์ฟแล้วก็ตีลูก
กอล์ฟอยู่ตรงนี้
ค่ะลูกกอล์ฟไปแล้วลอยไปแล้ว
ลอยออกไปทางด้านนู้นแหละอ่ะอ่า
โอเคไปไกลๆตีลูกกรอบออกไปแล้ว ka เป็นนัก
กอล์ฟหน้าจอ 2 ครูอาร์ทตี้ตีกอล์ฟได้ไหม
คะ 5 ขวดตีกอล์ฟได้ครับได้ฮ่าๆๆตีกอล์ฟ
ได้อ้ะ
[เพลง]
คู๋แอบเก๋เคยปีกอล์ฟไหมครับ
1 ครั้งขอ
ลูกกอล์ฟอยู่ที่นี่
นายกอล์ฟปุ้ย
ๆไม่ได้ไม่ได้ไม้ต้องอยู่ที่นี่ไม้อยู่
ที่เราลูกกอล์ฟไปลูกกอล์ฟไปห้องครูเคไม้
ไม้กอล์ฟไปไป
อยู่อ่ะถ้าไม่โอเคราคาอ่าอันนี้อ่ากีฬา
ที่ 1 นะคะอีหล่ากอล์ฟใช้กับ
กูอะติ๊ดตี่กอล์ฟได้หน้า f  e กอล์ฟไม่
ได้นักเรียนตีกอล์ฟได้ไหมครับอ่ะดีได้ไหม
เม้นข้างล่างอ้าโอเคนี่
ครับหาต่อไปครับ
กลับไปเป็นอะไรอ่ะต่อไปเป็นกีฬา
ฟุตบอลครับอ่าคุณมองอะไรคะเนี่ยหานี้อัน
นี้เป็นรูปฟุตบอล
ลูกฟุตบอลอาใช่ครับมีสีอะไรบ้างลูกฟุตบอล
อันนี้มีสีสีดำและก็มีสีขาว
อ่าสีดำสีขาวสีดำสีขาวสลับกันไปดำขาวดำ
ขาวทรายครับอ่าดำขาวแนะนำขาว R  R ลูกบอล
เป็นรูปกลมเหมือนกันลมลมขับ
ลูกบอลลูนเรียกว่าลูกฟุตบอลได้ครับสำหรับ
นักกีฬาอะไรคะ 5 สำหรับกีฬานะฟุตบอลครับ
นี่นักพุธผ่อนใช่ครับห่าและลูกบอลนี่เค้า
ต้องให้เขาก็จะไปแล้วเนี่ยอ้าลูกบอลเตะ
ใช่ครับใช้เท้าใช้เท้าเตะ
ฟุตบอลน่าใช้ครับใช้มือใช้มือไม่ได้ใช้
ไม้ไม่ได้ต้องใช้เท้าตรงไหนคะอรทัยเท้านะ
ครับเป็นฟุดฟุดฟุดภาษาอังกฤษแปลว่าเท้า
ใช่ๆเราก็เลยต้องใช้ถาวอ่ะได้เท้าเล่น
ฟุตบอลเตะฟุตบอลได้ใช้ครับอ่ะเอ่อ
อุปกรณ์กีฬาจะไปอ้ากีฬาต่อไปเป็นกีฬานี้
อันนี้ครับอ่า
เดี๋ยวนะอ่านักเรียนนักเรียนรู้จักรู้จัก
กีฬานี้ไหมครับ
อะไรอันนี้แล้วอุปกรณ์กีฬาถ้าได้ครับอัน
นี้เป็นรูปลูกรูปตะกร้อครับลูกตะกร้อได้
ครับมีมีสีเหลืองกับสีเขียวได้มีสีเหลือง
แล้วก็มีสีเขียวตรงนี้ใช่ครับอ่ะเรียกว่า
ลูกตะกร้อ
ครับ
รู้จักร้านเนี่ยสำหรับกีฬาอะไรคะอ้ารูป
ตะกร้อสำหรับกีฬาตะกร้อครับเป็นกีฬา
ตะกร้อคนไทยคนไทยชอบเล่นตะกร้อ
อ้าใช้และก็มีนักตะกร้อจะมีนักตะกร้อด้วย
นี่ก็มีลูกตัดอ้อยอยู่ตรงนี้ตะกร้อก็ใช้
เท้าเหมือนกันใช้เท้าเตะ
ส่วนของร่างกายได้แต่ไม่ใช้มือไม่ได้
เบอร์ไม่ได้ใช้อะไรบ้างคะเหนื่อยเช้าใช้
ข่าวขายสอบใช้ถ่ายใช้หัวได้ๆใช้มือไม่ได้
ห้ามใส่มือผัวก็ซึ่งๆๆครับๆ
โอเคแล้ว
ก็ช่อขับอตี้เล่นแล้วพูดเล่นนะคะนี่นา
ตะกร้อไหมคะอ่ะขวดอี้เล่นนิดหน่อยและนิด
หน่อยตายครับคนไทยพูดว่าเล่นแต่ถ้าฟุตบอล
ก็เล่นฟุตบอลเล่นฟุตบอลเล่นตะกร้อ
หาเล่น of ใต้ครับเล่นกีฬาเล่นอะไรค่ะอ่ะ
เล่นกีฬาหน้าเล่นกีฬาตายขับไม่มี
กี่อุปกรณ์ชิ้นต่อไปได้เห้อกีฬาต่อไปเป็น
หน้าอุปกรณ์นี่ครับเป็นฟิวค่ะไรครับสีขาว
อีกหาครับพูดครูเอ๋พูดลูกขนไก่อ๋ออ๋อลูก
ขนไก่นี่ครับมันมีขนไก่อยู่ตรงนี้ลูกขน
ไก่นะครับหน้าหรือเราเรียกว่าดูขนไก่หรือ
เรียกลูกแบดมินตัน
มั่วๆแบดมินตันคนไทยเรียกสั้นๆคนไทยเรียก
สั้นเขาเรียกลูกแบต
ฮ่าๆลูกโอเค
โอเคอะไรนะสุดท้ายสั้นๆรูปแบบลูกแบตชาย
ครับลูกแบตสีขาวอ่า ami มีนักกีฬาแบบไหน
เนี่ยนักกีฬาเราพูดว่าอะไรคะอ้านักกีฬา
เราก็พูดว่านะแบดมินตันงวดนะตายครับ
หรือเราพูดสั้นๆนักแบต
แบตก็
ได้ครับปีแบตหน้าเราไม่เรียกเราไม่เรียก
ไม่เรียกเล่นแบบไม่เรียกเรียกตีแบต
แล้วเขามีอะไรตีค่ะอ่าอ่ะเขาใช้ไม้นี่ใช้
ไม้ไม้ก็เรียกไม้แบตใจครับเออใช้อ่ะนี่
รูปแบบลอยมาตรงนี้ไม้ตี
พรุ่งนี้อ้าได้เขา
เข้าใจอ่าครับ
นี้อันอื่นอีกไหมคะ 5 มีกีฬาอีกครับห่าไป
ครับตอนก่อน
อุปกรณ์กีฬากีฬาหน้านี้นี่เป็นลูกลูกกลม
กลมเหมือนกันอ่ะลูกนี้นี่มีมีสีสีเหลือง
หน้ามีสีขาวหนังสีขาวมีสีน้ำเงินโอเคมี 3
สีนะครับอ่าลูกนี้เรียกลูกวอลเลย์บอล
อ้าววอลเลย์บอลเรียกลูกวอลเลย์บอลไปครับ
เล่นกับ
กีฬาอะไรเปิดเล่นขับที่รักวอลเลย์บอลครับ
เนอะกีฬาวอลเล่ฮะคนที่เล่นวอลเลย์บอลเรา
เรียกนะ
วอลเลย์บอลอ้านี่นักวอลเลย์บอลอ่ะ
วอลเลย์บอลใช้ใช้มือใช้มือ
นะครับคะใช้ขาไม่ได้ไม่ได้ใจครับใช้มือ
แฮปปี้เล่นควรเลย์บอลได้ไหม ahh ขวดอี
เล่นวอลเลย์บอลได้นิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยนะอ่า
ใช่ครับเก่ง
อ่าคู๋เคยเล่นวอลเลย์บอลไหมครับ
น้าฮ่าๆๆ
แสดงว่านานมาก
นานมากสิ
เด็กๆเหรอเรียนวอลเลย์บอลออนไลน์น้อ
โป้เดกโคโยตี้ก็เรียนเรียนวอลเลย์บอล
เหมือนกันพอ
ดีชั่วเจ็บตายๆๆจะเจ็บเจ็บมือเวลาตีก็จะ
เจ็บๆ
[เพลง]
โอ้ยเจ็บ
บางทีบางทีลูกวอลเลย์บอล
ลูกวันโดนหัวได้มั๊ยแต่
นะคะลูกวอลเลย์บอลข่าวสำหรับนักกีฬา
วอลเลย์บอล
อ้าวถูกต้องครับ
ตาไปอ้าวมีกีฬาอะไรคะค่ะมีอีก 1 อย่าง
ครับมีอีก 1 อ่างต่อไปเป็นนี่ครับ
5 อันนี้เป็นไงลูกบอลตัวปลมเหมือนกันอ่ะ
ลูกบอลกลมๆสีสีส้ม
ซ่าส์ค่าซ่อมอยู่ที่นี่อ้าสิ
ปีส้มอ๋อสวัสดีคะมีเบอร์ที่มีส้ม
แพนซีเหมือนเหมือนสีไม่เหมือน
โอเคอ่ารูปบอลสีส้มอ่ะใช้ครับเรียกลูกลูก
เท่าไหร่คะบาสเกตบอล
หน้ามาสเก็ตบอลมาใส่ขับลูกบาสเกตบอลลูก
บาสเก็ตบอลสำหรับนักกีฬาอะไรคะลูก
บาสเกตบอลสำหรับกีฬานะบาสเกตบอลครับอ่า
อ้านี้นักบาสเกตบอลคนนี้
นักเก็ตบอลนะคะถ่ายครับโอ้นักบาสนัก
บาสเกตบอล
สูงใช่ครับตัวสูง
สูง Black  market บอลสูง 2  2 เมตรข้อ 2
เมตรให้ครับ
นายครับสูงมาก
ตายแล้วก็ต้องวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งเร็วด้วยวิ่ง
เร็ววิ่งเร็วนะกระโดดได้ครับกระโดดกระโดด
กระโดดห้าใช่ครับกระโดด
and โหด k  r หน้าตอนนี้เรารู้จักกีฬาไป
ทั้งหมดมีกีฬาอะไรบ้างครับนักเรียนรู้จัก
นักกีฬาก่อนเนาะอ้านักกีฬาอะไรบ้างเริ่ม
จากนักนักบาสเกตบอลนักบาสเกตบอล
แล้วก็มีนี่นะนักวอลเล่บอลเล่บอลน่ะ
นัดแบตไว้อ้าวนักแบดมินตันใช่ครับนัดแบต
ก็ได้คนไทยเรียกสั้นๆนะเคต่อไป
นัดกับกรอ
และก็ก็ใช่ครับ
นักฟุตบอลหน้านักฟุตบอลแล้วก็สุดท้าย
นักกอล์ฟกอล์ฟใช่ครับม้าโอเคว้าวต่อไปนัก
กีฬากอล์ฟก็ o.k.
o.k.
ได้ครับแล้วก็อุปกรณ์
นักกอล์ฟก็มีอะไรคะนักกอล์ฟก็มีลูกกอล์ฟ
ไม้กอล์ฟไม้กอล์ฟใช่ครับ
ต่อไปเป็นเอ่อนักฟุตบอลก็ตำรวจมาตำรวจมา
ทำไมต่อไปเป็นนักฟุตบอลนักฟุตบอลก็มี
อุปกรณ์เป็นลูกบอลหาใช่ครับเป็นรูปต้น
บอนไซครับหน้าต่อไปเป็นนัดก็นัดกับพ่อ
และก็ 5 คนกีฬาคืออะไรคะคือลูกตะกร้อครับ
ลูกตะกร้อ 5 ต่อไปเป็นนะ
แบดมินตันนักแบดมินตันอ่าก่อนเล่น
แบดมินตันอะไรคะถ้าเป็นลูบแบดมินตันครับ
รูปแบบหนึ่งตันอ่า
แล้วก็มีนักวอลเลย์บอลนักวอลเลย์บอลคู่
กับอุปกรณ์หน้าคู่กับรูปวอลเลย์บอลครับ
กวนเล่นบอลตายครับอ่าอ้าต่อไปอ่ะเป็น 5
ขวดตี้มีแก้เกมมาให้เล่นนะครับอ่ามาให้
ไม่ครูเอ๋กับนักเรียนช่วยกันหาหาหาอ้าหา
นะอีหล่าหานักกีฬาใช่ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวควร
เต็มที่จะบอกจะบอกหาว่ามี
อะนี่นิกรอะไรแล้วก็นักกีฬาอยู่ไหนน้าใช่
เขา
เมื่อวานแล้วก็เล่นแบบนี้เนาะเมื่อวานเรา
เล่นเปิดได้ 1 หรือ 2 ห่า
ครูเอ๋อยากเปิดกี่คำ
มั่นใจว่ากูเอกเก่งเนี่ยถูกแน่นอนด้วย
ครับถูกมั้ย
1155 เดี๋ยวขวดอี้อ่ากำหนดอุปกรณ์กีฬา
ก่อนเอาเอาเอานี้เอาลูกกอล์ฟก่อน
ลูกกอล์ฟจะต้องใครเล่นลูกกอล์ฟครับ
นักกอล์ฟโอเคแค่แล้วนักกอล์ฟอยู่หมายเลข
มีอะไรครับอ่าอยู่หมายเลขหมายเลข
หมายเลข 555 กลัวตีจะเปิดใหม่เลยครั้ง
แล้วนะว่ามีนึก Got  You หน้ามั้ยมี
ขายแลกอ่ะหน้านะครับไปแล้วน้ำเปิด 5 เปิด
แล้วครับหนึ่งสอง
ถ้า
ด่าใช่
ไม่ใช่น้ำก่อนหมายเลขหน้า 8 เมตรล้านเป็น
อะไรครับนักแบตมาไม่ใช่ไม่ๆครับๆ
พี่เอ๋ไม่ได้คะแนนไม่ได้คะแนนออมในศูนย์
อ่าครับโอ้อ.
ปกรณ์ชิ้นต่อไปอุปกรณ์ชิมต่อไปกินต่อไป
เดี๋ยวกลัวตี้เอาเอานี่ครับ
ลูกฟุตบอลลูกฟุตบอล
ใหม่เล่นลูกฟุตบอลครับต้องหาใครฟุตบอล
ต้องหานักฟุตบอล
ต้องหานักฟุตบอลนะว่านักฟุตบอลอยู่อยู่
อยู่หมายเลขอะไรครับ
ครูเอกคิดอ่าต้องคิดคลิปๆๆดีคิดดึก
หมายเลขหมายเลข 4 ค่ะบ่ายเลข 4 หมายเลข 4
อยู่ร้องนี้นี้หมายเลข 4
นักเรียนนักเรียนคิดว่าคิดว่าให้ไหมใช่
หรือไม่ใช่ 5 ขวดก็ไม่รู้กวนตีก็ไม่รู้
เป็นคัน
โอเคกวนตีน Shop เปิดจะเปิดเลยค่ะอีกแล้ว
นะเพลินเลย 1 เอง 2
3 ตา
ด่าฮาเฮ
ฟุตบอลให้นักอะไร
นะตะกร้อ
ใหม่ใช่ไม่ได้คะแนนออก
ออกๆก่อน
เจ๊นะครับอ่าเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้ปิดก่อนไหมครับ
ต่อไปเอากีฬาอุปกรณ์กีฬาอะไรดีเอา
ๆนี่ครับ
ลูกอะไรครับรู้จักกับ 5 ลูกตะกร้ออ้าแล้ว
ไปนัดนาอะไรเล่นตะกร้อครับหมอนัดตะกร้า
ตะกร้อนี่นักสักรอบเป็นแบบนี้นักเรียนนัก
เรียนช่วยครูเหคิดคิดว่า Hack ก็
ก็อยู่หมายเลขเท่าไหร่
รูปเล็ก 4 ใช่ไหมโอเค
ใช่หรือไม่ใช่ครับหน้าคนที่จะเปิดแล้วนะ
หาดา
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ห่าครูเอ๋รับไป 1 คะแนน and  a โอเคนะ
ครับ 5 ต่อไปกีฬาอุปกรณ์กีฬาต่อไปต่อไป
เป็นเป็นอันนี้ครับนี่ 8  5 รูปบาท
ลูกแบบรูปแบบหน้าแล้วใครนักกีฬาอะไรเล่น
ลูกแบตครับนะแบดมินตันอ่านักแบดมินตันนัก
เรียนช่วยครูเอ๋หาหานักแบดมินตัน
ก๋วยตี้ ver ตี้คิดว่าครูเอ๋จำได้คู่เบส
จากเนี่ยฮ่าๆๆจำได้นักกีฬาแบดมินตันอยู่
หมายแรกหมายเลข
กลัวดิ๊ยังไม่ได้ถามเลยเหตุตอบแล้วกู
เห็นกลัวกลัวลืมกลัวลืม
นักกีฬาแบดมินตันอยู่หมายเลขอะไรครับอยู่
หมายเลขอะไรหมายเลข
ขอ
หมายเลข 5 ด้วยมั้ยคือว่าตี้ก็จำได้จำได้
ว่านักกีฬาแบดมินตันอยู่ไหนเลขหมายเลขห้า
ถูกมั้ยนักเรียนคิดว่าใช่ไหมใช่นะ 1
สาดา
ครับ
ต่อไปต่อไปต่อไปครับ
ต่อไปคืออะไรคะกลัวตีกว่าที่จะเปิดอันที่
ครูเอ๋
เคยตอบนะจะได้
เลือกง่ายๆเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้เลือกอุปกรณ์กีฬา
ก่อนนะมีอุปกรณ์กีฬาอะไรพี่ยังยังไม่ได้
ถามครับมีไหม
อ้าวลูกวอลเลย์บอลโอเคลูกวอลเลย์บอล
คะนักกีฬาอะไรเล่นรูปวอลเลย์บอลครับนัก
วอลเลย์บอล 5 นักวอลเลย์บอลนะโอเคนัก
เรียนนักเรียนช่วยครูเอ๋คิดนะครับว่าณนะ
วาเล่บอลยูทูบายแลกอะไรครับ
มีสี Choice อย่างไม่ได้เปิด
อ่า
สักขวดตีตัวดิเปิดให้เปิดสองรูปให้เปิด
จองรูปขอบคุณค่ะคือเบอร์
1 ค่ะเบอร์ 1 นะครับๆเดี๋ยวเปิดเบอร์ 1
ก่อนฮะอ่าใช่หรือไม่ใช่ครับเบอร์หนึ่งอา
เปิดแล้วนะเนอะ
ถ้าได้
ฟุตบอลๆครับอาอามาให้ได้
หน้าเปิดอีกเปิดอีก 1  1 รูปครับเบอร์
6 ค่ะอาคู๋เลือกเอกคิดคิดว่านักฟุตบอล
อยู่ก็นะกวนแล้วบอกคนนึงครับวอลเลย์บอล
ด้วยนะยี่ Cool เบอร์ 6
วอลเลย์บอลยูเบอร์ 6 อยู่อยู่หรือไม่อยู่
ครับอยู่อยู่ๆใช่ไหมอ่ะวันนี้จะเปิดแล้ว
นะครับ
[เพลง]
ชาดา
โอ้ยน้ำก่อน
นักกอล์ฟมาอยู่หมายเลขอบมิเองโอเค
5 ต่อไปอ่ะยังเหลืออีกกีฬา
และสุดท้ายอีก 1  1 อุปกรณ์กีฬาเป็น
อุปกรณ์อะไรที่ยังไม่ได้เลือกครับก็
ปิดก่อน
องค์กรอะไรที่ยังไม่ได้เลือกโอเคเดี๋ยวนะ
นี่ครับหนี
ลูกอะไรครับนะเดี๋ยวคู่ปาร์ตี้เมื่อกี้
ไม่ใช่นักฟุตบอล
โลก
บาสเกตบอล basketball ใช่ครับสีส้มนะแล้ว
บ้านนักกีฬาอะไรนักกีฬาอะไรเล่น
บาสเก็ตบอลครับนักกีฬานักบาส 5 นัดบาสใช่
ไหมครับอ่ะครูเอ๋นักเรียนต้องช่วยคู๋หาหา
นักบาสนะครับว่านักบาสอยู่เลขไหนครับหมด
อ้ะเป็นคู๋ขา
เว้จำได้เสื้อจำได้ที่
อยู่แรกไหนครับอยู่แล้วหนึ่งค่ะอ้าวขวด
พี่ก็คิดว่าคิดว่าน่าจะใช่อ่ะใช่หรือไม่
ใช่ครับอ่า
เกิดจะเปิดแล้วนะครับ
r12
ชา
ดาษไปแถวๆ
ครับถูกต้องแต่ทำไมครัวตี้รวมคะแนนได้ 3
คะแนน
3 คะแนนแล้วข้างบนทำไมมันมีทำไมตั้งนาน
ไม่เป็นไรอ่ะกูเอได้ 3 คะแนน
3 คะแนนนะครับอ้าเดี๋ยวกลัวที่เปิด
เปิดให้ดูให้หมดเลยอะมีนักวอลเลย์บอลอยู่
นี่แล้วก็หมายเลข 3 เป็นอะไรครับเจ๊โป้
ออนบอลอะหมายเลข 4 เป็นอะไรครับนักตะกร้อ
หมายเลข 5 เป็นนักแบดมินตันแบดมินตันโอเค
แล้วก็หมายเลขสุดท้ายหมายเลข 6 เป็นนัก
กอล์ฟโอเคห้าวันนี้เราก็ได้รู้จักต่อนัก
กีฬาใช่ไหมครับพี่นานแล้วก็รู้จักรู้จัก
อุปกรณ์กีฬาได้ครับ
โอเคอ้าวันนี้หมดเวลาอะดี
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าก็มาเจอกับครัวตี้กับ
ครูพี่เอ๋เอ๋แบบในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสิเบิ้ล
ไทยการใหม่นะครับอ้าวันนี้ครัวตีต้อง
สวัสดีก่อนครับ 5 สวัสดีครับนักเรียนครับ
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ครับผม 5 ครับผมบ๊ายบายน
ม.ค